es wird eine gigantische planeten
maschine dass dresden experiment denn
hier wird nichts geringeres als das
magnetfeld der erde nachgebaut der
absolute wahnsinn
und vielleicht gibt sie uns sogar
hinweise darauf ob und wann sich das
magnetfeld demnächst möglicherweise um
bolt und welche fatalen folgen für das
leben auf der erde dieses ereignis mit
sich bringen würde
wir freuen uns dieses thema von pm mit
exklusivem material aus dem aktuellen
heft übernehmen zu können
in zusammenarbeit mit der zeitschrift
gibt es übrigens noch ein hammer
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr ein bresser
messe teleskop gewinnen könnt also los
geht's herzlich willkommen und einen
riesen dank an pm eine zeitschrift bei
der die gleiche begeisterung für
wissenschaft vorherrscht wie bei uns und
die genauso viel wert auf gute recherche
wahrheit und fakten legt für die
ungeduldigen ist der link zum
gewinnspiel übrigens in der infobox wenn
man sich da weiter krieg kommt man auch
zu den genauen teilnahmebedingungen es
handelt sich um eine echte
höllenmaschine am rande des technisch
machbaren
die rede ist vom dresden projekt
weltweit wohl das ehrgeizigste
experiment zur erforschung des
erdmagnetfeldes am helmholtz-zentrum
dresden-rossendorf entsteht mitten im
wald die anlage namens dresden das steht
für dresdner natrium anlage für dynamo
und therme hydraulik forschung ab 2022
soll hier ein künstliches mini
erdmagnetfeld erschaffen werden
damit will die wissenschaft endlich den
vielen mysteriösen rätsel rund um diesen
wirklich so bedeutenden schutzschirm der
erde auf die schliche kommen
doch noch wird das experiment aufgebaut
wer die forschungs halle betritt steht
vor einer inneren halle mit schweren
betonwänden die forschenden nennen das
containment ein begriff den man sonst
für die innerste sicherheitshülle von
kernkraftwerken nutzt und dass es
tatsächlich passen denn dieses
containment ist mit dem in einem
atomkraftwerk vergleichbar die anlage
ist ein absoluter gigant am rande des
technisch machbaren
im zentrum des containments steht ein
sockel auf gewaltigen beinen aus beton
darauf liegt eine drehbare plattform auf
ihr thront ein stählerner koloss mit
viera mehr sold by das herzstück der
anlage tragen
die rede ist von einem tonnenschweren
zylindrischen tank der nicht nur zwei
meter hoch ist sondern auch
einen durchmesser von zwei metern hat
der behälter soll unseren erdkern
simulieren also den ort der unglaubliche
3000 bis 6000 kilometer unter unseren
füßen liegt hier entspringt nämlich das
erdmagnetfeld und auch wenn es uns
ständig umgibt hat die wissenschaft es
trotz intensiver forschung noch nicht
vollständig verstanden klar ist nur dass
wir es in unserem alltag so gut wie nie
bemerken dabei ist es super wichtig für
uns denn es stimmt unserem planeten vor
gefahren ab unter anderem schützt es uns
vor den elektrisch geladenen teilchen
die bei sonnensturm in massen auf die
erde prasseln das magnetfeld lenkt sie
ab und so erreichen sie der erde im
besten fall erst gar nicht wenn sie über
polregionen in die atmosphäre eindringen
entstehen polarlichter ein wunderschönes
buntes spektakel und eine folge der
kosmischen abwehr zudem bietet uns das
erdmagnetfeld auch vor kosmischen
geschossen die aus den tiefen des
weltalls herausschießen schutz ein
großes glück für uns denn wenn die
teilchen aus dem all ungehindert auf die
erdatmosphäre treffen würden würden sie
die ozonschicht angreifen
doch die schützt uns vor der
uv-strahlung der sonne die folge wäre
nicht nur ein erhöhtes hautkrebsrisiko
möglicherweise hätte das in der
vergangenheit sogar die entwicklung des
lebens auf der erde bremsen können also
zum glück gibt es das erdmagnetfeld mit
dem kompass können wir uns an dem
orientieren und auch manche tiere
orientieren sich am magnetfeld einige
bakterien insekten reptilien vögel und
sogar säugetiere wie die fledermaus
haben einen inneren kompass doch bisher
weiß man nicht welche organe ihnen
diesen siebten magnetsinn ermöglichen
auch andere super spannende fragen rund
um das erdmagnetfeld sind noch
unbeantwortet wie entsteht es genau
warum schwankt seine stärke und warum
holte sich alle paar hunderttausend
jahre um fest stehen bislang nur das
magnetfeld der erde entsteht durch
fließende metalle
denn bei rund 4000 grad celsius fließen
im äußeren erdkern flüssiges eisen und
nickel um den festen inneren erdkern das
läuft sehr langsam ab konkret fließt das
flüssige eisen mit rund einen millimeter
pro sekunde also rund dreieinhalb metern
pro stunde
doch wie genau entsteht dabei das
magnetfeld dieses mysteriöse rätsel soll
nun endlich mit hilfe von dresden
geklärt werden unglaubliche acht tonnen
flüssiges natrium im tank nehmen hier
die rolle der metalle im erdkern ein
damit diese natrium tank ein magnetfeld
entspringt muss einiges mit ihm
passieren weil der planet um sich selbst
rotiert
wird auch der 33 tonnen schwere tank in
rotation versetzt vor angetrieben von
einem elektromotor der sechs kubikmeter
große behälter lässt sich um 45 bis 90
grad kippen
und dann wird endgültig klar warum
dresden eine höllenmaschine ist denn der
gesamte gut 130 tonnen schwere aufbau
steht selbst auf einer drehbaren
plattform und diese dreht sich mit bis
zu einer umdrehung pro sekunde
da wirken wirklich gigantische kräfte
fachleute bezeichnen die resultierende
bewegung als sogenannte präzession diese
ist der taumel bewegung der erdachse im
all nachempfunden letztere spielt sich
allerdings nicht in sekunden sondern
über viele tausend jahre ab doch das
dresdner experimente ist natürlich sehr
viel kleiner als die erde und so musste
sich entsprechend schneller drehen um
denselben effekt hervorzurufen
der stahlkoloss hat dabei die größe
eines kleinbusses und das gewicht eines
vollen schiffscontainer dennoch soll es
sich vilser drehen als jedes karussell
es tut die sensoren am rand des
rotationsverfahren dann mit rund 250
kilometern pro stunde im kreis der
elektromotor wird eine fliehkraft
erfahren die dem 15-fachen seiner
gewichtskraft entspricht auch der
rotation behälter muss viel aushalten
acht tonnen flüssiges natrium werden
aufgrund der rotation mit 20 bar auf die
außenwände gedrückt außerdem wird der
tank einen wechsel druck erfahren der
zehn mal pro sekunde um 8 bar schwankt
nur so kann das erdmagnetfeld
realistisch simuliert werden denn die
entstehung des magnetfeldes der erde ist
ein hoch komplexer prozess nicht nur die
bewegten massen und kräfte sind gewaltig
es gibt auch viele effekte die sich
gegenseitig verstärken oder eben
auslöschen selbst hochleistungsrechner
können das nur ansatzweise berechnen
zugleich ist der prozess sensibel wenn
nicht alle rahmenbedingungen stimmen
entsteht kein stabiles magnetfeld das
ist schon fast paradox in experimenten
ist es super kompliziert solch ein
magnetfeld herzustellen die erde dagegen
bekommt das zufällig hin und das seit
jahrmillionen und ohne dieses magnetfeld
wäre die erde fiel lebensfeindlicher als
mit das ist schon verrückt wie perfekt
hier alles passt damit leben existieren
kann der erdmagnetismus gehört mit zu
den entscheidenden rahmenbedingungen für
die existenz von uns menschen in der
theorie wird der prozess beschrieben
durch die
netto hydrodynamik sie erklärt das
verhalten elektrisch leitfähiger
flüssigkeiten und zudem gehört eben auch
die heiße mischung aus eisen und nickel
im äußeren erdkern dort sorgen zwei
effekte dafür dass das flüssige metall
in bewegung gerät zum einen gibt der
erdkern auch nach viereinhalb milliarden
jahren noch hitze ab und sorgt für
konvektion ströme die heißen metalle
strömen nach außen kühlen sich ab und
sinken wieder hinab vergleichbar ist das
mit einer lavalampe zum anderen wirkt
die drehung der erde eine starke
corioliskraft die alle bewegung zur
seite ablenkt in der summe ergeben sich
verdrehte strömungen im äußeren erdkern
es ist wirklich eine riesige
herausforderung diesen effekt zu
erzeugen das flüssige metall muss im
schrauben förmige bahnen gezogen werden
dabei hat das magnetfeld die tendenz
schneller zu zerfallen
als es durch die strömung indiziert wird
in der erde treibt die wärme bewegung
dem prozess an doch das lässt sich in
experimenten kaum nachbilden dort muss
die panischen nachgeholfen werden dass
dresden forschungsteam probierte es per
präzession in dem also der tank in
verschiedene richtungen zugleich dreht
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben die komplizierte
mathematik der magneto hydrodynamik
immer wieder berechnet sie sind
zuversichtlich dass sie die effekte so
nachahmen können spannend dabei ist auch
die beobachtung dass sich das
erdmagnetfeld immer wieder mal um pult
dabei ist sogar eine gewisse
regelmäßigkeit zu erkennen diese
umpolung folgen eine mehrere
hunderttausend jahre umfassenden
rhythmus bei dem sich das magnetfeld
immer wieder abschwächt und wenn das
passiert sind die auswirkungen fatal
denn das bombardement der geladenen
teilchen könnte unsere gesamte
zivilisation bedrohen nicht nur die
kommunikationstechnik sondern auch die
elektronik und die stromnetze auf der
erde könnten durch sonnenstürme
beschädigt werden neben blackouts gäbe
es wohl dann auch eine zunahme der
krebserkrankung die dresdner
forscherinnen und forscher aber sind
zuversichtlich dass in naher zukunft
keine polo kann steht doch dafür hoffen
sie umso mehr sie schon bald im labor
beobachten zu können apropos beobachtung
jetzt gibt es noch dieses wirklich
sensationelle teleskop zu gewinnen mit
einer ganz hervorragende optik und auch
die steuerung hat es in sich denn sie
macht es möglich in extrem kurzer zeit
objekte am himmel zu finden ein
absoluter traum dafür einfach auf den
link unten in der video beschreibung
klicken kleiner geheimtipp die
zu gewinnen sind ziemlich gut außerdem
gibt es obendrauf auch noch zwei gratis
ausgaben des magazins inklusive der
aktuellen ausgabe dahin gibt es noch
viel mehr infos zu dem super spannenden
dresden projekt aber natürlich noch
viele weitere wichtige themen aus der
wissenschaft und forschung zum beispiel
zu den beiden außenseitern im
sonnensystem uranus und neptun die viele
geheimnisse bergen oder aber wie
forschungsteams mit erstaunlichen tricks
die wundheilung perfektionieren wollen
um in zukunft störende narben schon im
vorfeld zu verhindern richtig spannend
aber auch der artikel dazu wie
exoskelett in vielen firmen den menschen
die arbeit erleichtern und dabei muskeln
und gelenke schon also wenn er interesse
daran haben dann klickt unbedingt hier
drauf hier gibt es auch das teleskop zu
gewinnen ich drücke euch auf jeden fall
schon mal die daumen bis dann bleib dran